Gary played me a piece of tape I was on
your TV show in 2006 and they had just
announced that you were going to be The
Tonight Show replacement for Jay when
Jay retired and and was many years off
right and I turned to you on your show
and I was half being funny but I said um
it's going to go horribly wrong when
their time comes Jay will [__] not
let you have that show yeah and the
audience was going wild and they were
laughing and you were even like hey it's
hundred years from now it's never going
to you know and I said wow I sound like
I knew what I was talking about I mean
you knew exactly what you were talking
about yeah I you know I look back on
that whole thing which was you know
craziness but um and I don't like to
talk about it much and I'll I'll tell
you why yeah why I don't like to talk
about it much and in fact I really try
to avoid talking about it because for a
long time I decided first of all nobody
in Show Business should complain it's
just rule number one don't comp you
sound like a whining you make that kind
of money no we make crazy money and
we're getting to live out our dreams and
then you're complaining and anyone
listening uh is rightfully thinking
you're a jackass but the other point is
on my TBS show there were a couple I
really made a point to like I'm going to
be positive and I'm just going to keep
doing it and guests because it was the
big thing would bring it up and ask me
about it right and they would and and I
would make a joke to try and I just make
a joke about the whole and gloss over it
and then I would read the next day Conan
can't get you know let over it and you
the thing is I I I think I saw I saw I
saw Let It Go and I remember thinking a
guest asked me about on the how do I let
it go and if I talk about it for a
second someone's saying like oh my God
Conan you know enough shut up and so
what people don't understand is that you
beat the odds and it's rarified a to get
a talk show and to be in this kind of
thing and people don't understand
another thing I remember there was a
point where Fox TV came to you and said
we're going to give you 20 something
crazy $28 million to jump over to Fox
NBC heard about it they said to you well
we're going to give you $8 million
but we're going to give you the Tonight
Show when Jay retires yeah and you had
such a fixation for The Tonight Show as
many performers do because it's rare to
get that offer you said I'll [__] the
$21 million [__] you fox I'll stay with
NBC because I want that tonight show I
want my shot here's the other thing I
never made a decision in my career based
on money not once I'm not going to lie
it's nice to have money right but I've
also not had money um and I'm okay with
that
I really
wanted to keep my body of work all I
ever wanted was a body of work and that
can sound pretentious to people but it
is the most important next to my family
my wife and kids my body of work is like
the most important thing to me it's your
legacy it's my legacy and I've put so
much into it and I'm really proud of the
good stuff I'm very proud of and so the
idea of leaving NBC on bad terms are
leaving and not having access to 16
years of work that I'm incredibly proud
of was crushing to me so I do not
regret anything I don't regret trying I
don't regret uh I I feel like a lot of
your career and in your life it's all
how you play the cards that you're dealt
and I was dealt certain cards at certain
times and I've been extremely fortunate
I am the poster boy for luck in show
business but I also think I've been
dealt cards at times which which aren't
the best and I'm proud of the way I
played
them